claire greenfield lives in sully hall in
the west midlands and she's a loyal
conservative but the leadership hopefuls
still have some persuading to do if
they're going to get her vote
ahead of this debate where are you
between the the two candidates russia
sonak liz truss
where are you leaning so at the moment
i'm undecided
between
rishi and liz
i am leaning towards liz truss more
and so
this debate
or hopefully make up my mind as a member
of the conservative party and i can
cast my vote with confidence
claire says she has doubts about rishi
sunak's motivations to become pm and liz
truss's recent climb down over her
policy to determine the salaries of
public sector workers based on where
they live
i think he supported the country very
well through covid
um however
the thing i don't like about him is the
i do feel he stabbed boris
in the back liz truss i like the fact
that she's been strong on the
international stage
especially against putin however i was
disappointed uh yesterday with this
u-turn
and i thought to myself is this
something that's
going to be
a
carry on the previous boris government
u-turning all the time
130 miles north in harrogate sue lumby
is yet to fully decide sue is 71 and a
councillor
i think they're good in that they're
very different we have a very clear view
on what they both they're both they're
both believe they're both directions i
think she's quite direct she's not
polished on camera and i like that i
like that
i think she's been a very good foreign
secretary generally i would agree with
rishi sooner over the tax situation i
don't think you can keep borrowing but
today in these days with the uk
ukraine crisis and therefore the fuel
crisis and everything else i think
people
poor people just can't take any more
squeezing
so i definitely favor this trust on that
one sue like claire will take her seat
in the audience at the sky news
leadership debate it's the last chance
the candidates will have to persuade
members before voting begins nick martin
sky news